Find it in a Subaru Crosstrek.
>> Bret: AMERICA'S ELECTION
HEADQUARTERS.
ITS PRIMARY DAY IN EIGHT STATES.
DEMOCRATS ARE HOPING TO WRESTLE
AT LEAST 23 HOUSE SEATS FROM
REPUBLICANS TO TAKE CONTROL THAT
CHAMBER.
MOST OF THE ATTENTION TO MY
DESIGN CALIFORNIA WHERE THAT
STATES UNUSUAL PRIMARY FORMAT
HAS OPENED ALL KINDS OF
POSSIBILITIES FOR THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT.
CORRESPONDED PETER DOOCY IS IN
SAN DIEGO TODAY.
>> ON JUNGLE PRIMARY DAY,
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
LEAPFROGGED.
>> THEY ARE CERTAINLY THE THIRD
MOST POPULAR GROUP.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE TOP TWO
PRIMARY CANDIDATES ADVANCE
REGARDLESS OF PARTY, THEY ARE
NOW MORE VOTERS REGISTERED AS
HAVING A PARTY PREFERENCE AND
THERE ARE REGISTER G.O.P.
DEMOCRATS REMAIN IN FIRST PLACE.
THAT MEANS TO WIN, REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES MUST GET CREATIVE.
>> THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
DOCTRINE REPUBLICANS.
IT GIVES THEM SOME FLEXIBILITY.
THE ELECTORATE MAY BE MORE
MODERATE THAN A RED STATE
STRATEGY WOULD DICTATE.
>> ONE CANDIDATE THINKS BETTER
REGISTRATIONS WILL COME WITH
BETTER G.O.P. CAMPAIGNS.
>> YOU START WINNING, NOBODY
WANTS TO BE WITH THE PARTY BUT
LOSES.
>> DEMOCRATS WHEN THE MORE
STATEWIDE BUT THEIR STATS ARE
STAGNANT.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS
HERE BECAUSE OUR NUMBERS HAVE
GROWN OVER THE 20 YEARS.
INSTEAD, WHAT HAPPENED IS PEOPLE
HAVE DECLINED TO STATE A
POLITICAL PARTY.
>> DESPITE THE DEMOCRAT LEAD,
COST MILLIONS TO COMPETE.
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRAT GAVIN
NEWSOM HAS SPENT ALMOST
$15 MILLION, ABOUT THREE TIMES
MORE THAN REPUBLICAN JOHN COX.
>> I'VE SEEN THIS MOVIE BEFORE.
FRONT RUNNERS TAKE THINGS FOR
GRANTED.
THEY READ THE -- MISREAD THE
POLES.
FOLKS DON'T TURN OUT BECAUSE
THEY THINK THEY'VE GOT IT.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE HAS PUMPED
MORE THAN $2 MILLION IN THE
RETIRING REPUBLICAN ED ROYCE'S
DISTRICT.
$1.6 MILLION ON RETIRING
REPUBLICAN DARRELL ISIS AND
$1.8 MILLION ON DANA
ROHRABACHER'S DISTRICT.
DEMOCRATS MIGHT NOT EVEN FINISH
HIGH ENOUGH TO MAKE IT TO THE
MIDTERMS.
THAT'S WHERE DEMOCRATS HARLEY
RUDA IS APPEALING TO THIS NUMBER
IN THE MIDDLE TO AVOID BEING
LEFT OUT THE NOVEMBER BALLOT.
>> MOST AMERICANS ARE BETWEEN
THE 20-YARD LINES.
THEY ARE TIRED OF THE PARTISAN
POLITICS.
>> EACH PARTY HAS A MATH
PROBLEM.
REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE AS MANY
REGISTERED MEMBERS AS THEY WOULD
LIKE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TOO MANY
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES
SPLITTING UP THE VOTE IN SOME
DISTRICTS.
IT MAKES IT UNCERTAIN DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES WILL MAKE IT PAST
TONIGHT AND EVERY SINGLE
DISTRICT AND I COULD SPOIL THEIR
SITES CHANCES OF SEATS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO RETAKE
THE HOUSE.
>> Bret: PETER DOOCY IN